[Music]
welcome to the good for you podcast
this episode you're gonna watch me fight
with my computer the entire time
benton can you describe our new visually
appealing
state of the art system we're not doing
for our opens did you guys ever have
fifth grade
and you had to do a presentation and
they said do it on powerpoint
and you said i'm going to drag pictures
and then write the name of pictures
that is it that's that's what you're now
doing
but now we're going to have a way more
multimedia
in your face mine have a laser pointer
mind bending whitney got one of those
yardsticks that she can point with
i might as well we're getting a
chalkboard that's hard for that's hard
for everyone involved
so anyway i am really working hard to
make a
a gorgeous and hilarious visual
experience
for the fans out there because a lot of
times we say oh remember this thing
happened remember this thing happened
and they're like oh i wish we could pull
up that photo and then i'm like
ah where is it it's good and then i
yeah the work goes on but then i don't
even know where it is and it's in a drop
box and it's in an adobe file it's in
the cloud
i don't know i thought the picture i put
in a jar yeah so i'm trying to i'm
trying to
so can you see this can people see this
now this is because this is the tim
dillon episode tim dillon
on good for you round two everyone in
this room can see it
that's the question i don't know it
hasn't went out yet it hasn't
you guys leave in the comments if you
can see this it hasn't been beamed it
hasn't been faxed over because if not we
didn't do it right you guys need to give
us your fax number so we can fax you all
of the elements that we're showing in
the show now yeah
i don't know i feel like this is going
to be really cool and
wonderful as soon as i figure it out
which will
not be soon so this is our gorgeous
interactive
it's not interactive i mean i guess you
can make comments in there
on the youtube click it goes to a
different video i know you know
how you can interact in the comments and
i know you will
also i'd like to address the fact that
it does look like i have a shiner
um and it's because i have some weird
allergy and i can't stop itching
i thought you were describing your
personality do you think do you think
that i
uh rubbed it too much or maybe i used
what got if you rubbed it like this yes
i feel like i got some of that
counterfeit you applaud it i i bought
makeup on benton i know
we we i stopped on amazon yeah i stopped
consulting you about where to buy makeup
and i think i i got my ass handed to me
in the form of pinkeye
someone just sent you i will buy brand
name products on amazon and i'm like oh
i can't believe this chanel eyeshadow is
only four bucks
i can't believe i got it in this alley
out of that man's coat and then i get it
and i'm like i just found a bargain
and then my eyes swell up and i look
like a leper
and you have pink eye i know and i keep
scratching it and anyway luckily this is
the color
i wanted if you guys think i look crazy
uh you're right can we talk about why
you and tanner
you and tan you and tim are so tainted
we should just yet
uh tan dad yeah we're t we look very tan
because we're in the dark here this is
we shot this episode um in there i went
to
uh texas i went to houston uh austin and
dallas in between
houston and dallas i was in austin for a
couple days and we're like oh why don't
we just like shoot a podcast like run
and gun
with tim because he's in austin and we
just did it with one camera
yeah i know where you were does tim live
outside
his shit tim is not known for protecting
his skin from the sun he likes to have
that like leathery
republican golfer vibe i came right from
arizona yeah that's like his aesthetic
um but yeah we just were in the dark and
tim i think is sunburn and it looks like
tan
and i'm an albino and just look a little
bit orange because i had to apply
cream blush by myself on your whole body
oh my entire body
so tim dillon is the guest on the show
today we are going to
uh now uh use this interactive uh
non-interactive this it's the science
show it's this is the science fair over
here good for you
um this is our powerpoint on um
health and hometown so first of all
benton
uh you have we have you have not
what is that is that a witch from no
that's um
that's like rubbing his chest the guy
from the princess bread why did he have
all those crusty herpes around his mouth
he's a
he's a monster slave i know but he
doesn't need to have like boils all over
his
bugs that was how do you know i read the
stories oh i thought that was so
that was such a bummer the fact that
that guy had to sit in here and make up
and then like yeah we're gonna make your
lips white and then just put a bunch of
fungus right in the corner of your lips
it would have been worse though if they
were like you don't need anything but it
was like
just head on off the camera perfect
bitch get out of here don't even put
makeup on you
um uh okay so have not seen you in a
minute
i saw a hilarious meme on your page uh
where you do a picture of your hometown
and it's a bunch of like super smiley
like
norm core looking like the perfect
family
and then compared to you saying what
you're just supposed to know what you're
doing and you're putting on red
uh eye shadow in the funniest way and
you all know this because it's up
on the keynote right now because i
dragged it and dropped it there
we've been taking a break we had a reset
yeah
i mean i've been taking whitney every
day for two years yep and she's seen me
over here for two years yes
that's a lot yes and we felt like you
know sometimes in relationships
especially when they're super super
close when you're so close and so
entrenched especially with the pandemic
i mean we were together every day all
day
like sharing soup from the same bowl i
mean we
love soup we were like sharing a twin
bed to sleep
whatever everybody had a twin bed
otherwise we're gone and throw them away
this is gonna this is gonna perpetuate
the fact that i live with you
you're gonna be like wait no wait dude
you do not live with me
uh you live inside my heart um it is a
studio apartment with no luck
i love those and sometimes when you're
so close to some
someone um too close it's not a healthy
kind of
uh entrenchment because then you start
hurting each other by accident because
you're so close
and haven't had a minute to like have
your own life well yeah we also forgot
all the
like you forget like is this work or
does this not work i can't remember what
we're doing right yeah yeah
so anyways we just took a little break i
took a little break to like remember all
the things that i like to do and all the
things that i like did before i came
here and like
refill my cup my whole thing with people
that you love
is you when things start getting
codependent sometimes you just need to
take a little break and a little bit of
space for yourself
and then re-engage after you've healed
some of your own wounds and not taking
anything personally
and and because when you're when you
don't know where you end and someone
else begins
it's really hard to not take the other
person's behavior personally because
you're so close i mean even as simple as
like you're staying at my house till
midnight every night and one day at
seven you're like i'm gonna head out and
it's like
moving normally if you stay still with
time oh yeah because
that aren't mean feel hurtful yeah and
also because
we're both like this but i'm like
someone who when i have a job i really
want to do the best i can do and i
forget sometimes
i forget to be a human being yeah yeah
become a job and i'm
very bad i just want to get a reaction
shot in case we needed it
all right we went to texas do you want
to hear about our texas trip yes i do we
went to
houston texas dallas austin grace
emily and i on a crazy road trip within
30 seconds of landing
i made them pull over the car so that i
could move roadkill off the road
and people don't understand that
vultures die a lot of animals die if
there's roadkill
in the middle of the street and the
problem is in texas the speed limit's
like 130
so there's so many dead animals in the
road so this is a squirrel
i had to move well wait wait pause this
video
you moved this squirrel yes so why
have you called me back to your home
multiple times to move birds and dead
squirrels
because i mean what is the video of me
throwing this screaming okay
benton i don't i'm calling your bluff on
how aggressive you are
there's a dead squirrel and benton's
gonna get it i am fully freaked out oh
it's up here
yeah hold on let's how long has it been
dead
oh god not that long
oh no oh yeah
that was the most tennessee backwood
shit i think i've ever seen
one of the smaller dead animals that
i've carried
that you did that with such ease yeah
can you tie it
heard you want to catch it take your
phone
it's just a squirrel
to pick up a squirrel you don't know
where it came from you made one of your
yard up
do you remember the drama when after
that in a bag the ones in my yard feel
like they're mine
and it's much more emotional this one
was just a carcass on the road and i
saw the the aftermath i saw the i saw
the uh basically we were driving and
these
beautiful vultures were driving and are
flying in the middle of the road trying
to get the squirrel almost getting hit
by cars over and over again so what am i
going to
be the hero or not one of my nominees
never called a voucher beautiful but i
think vultures are beautiful i think
they're cool too this is why i have this
big photo up right here
of uh lauren farr she does a ted talk
about how vultures
help solve crimes sometimes more
effectively than human beings and they
help with diseases because they eat them
out of those animals oh is that true you
know the first part of animal that they
eat
a disease no the first part of animal
the disease part
their eyes are their butthole yeah their
eyes are their buttholes they're the
softest parts that's right and then
their brains actually have brains and
intestines usually have the most
uh nourishment or um uh what's it called
uh
the most i hope it's nourishment hold on
uh yes
thank you halston the most nutrients of
any part of the animal so
if you see a corpse in the middle of a
forest and 30 feet away
leave the forest because what the hell
if you
uh see vulture feathers 30 feet away
from the body that means it was a
gunshot wound
because they flew to get that more
nutritious brain part
and they'll never move unless there's
some kind of uh
uh nutritional reward because they're
scavengers and they don't know when
they're gonna eat next
and they've got those tiny little heads
that's pretty cool and they're little
bald heads and then
so i did um start cleaning the road
because there was blood on the road
these vultures y'all got to slow down in
texas when you're driving
did you think the vultures were going to
stop and lick the blood up well no the
vultures you don't see it here but they
were flying into the road trying to get
any part they could so i had to keep
moving this carcass away and get them
out of
harm's way i cannot believe you touched
the squirrel i didn't touch it i used
you puked for 30 minutes when i got the
bag near you you don't bring that back
in there
look at everyone
[Laughter]
i want to know what prompted you to
bring jorts back so hardcore
i mean you have been rocking cut off and
i mean cut off in the mid thigh
george since i've been away i know ben
you said things have really fallen apart
since we've uh taken a reset
you said i need you know what i like i
like a good mid thigh cut off
i want you to know i have thighs but
don't look at them i don't want it to be
any higher
i'm a whore i'm not going to be a whoa
i'm not going to act like a hero okay
and that but i don't like them
too long because then that's a little
like um uh because they'll show your
birthday
you'll show your listen i can have my
booty cheek out if it's made of
i can't have my chicken cutlet butt
underwear hanging out that would look
crazy
and then we went to central texas pig
rescue which um you guys saw some of the
footage we are now gonna
we're gonna premiere some brand new
footage you have not seen uh premiere
will the full thing come out later
we're premiering it here we're gonna
start premiering
we are premiering footage these are our
podcasts now
and i need everyone to take this
seriously because it's really important
look at joe's eye on that picture he's
like so this is joe okay so for for
y'all that don't know
about two years ago i rescued i hate
when people say i rescued you you did
the least you could do you picked it up
and put it in your car just
not a lot this is a lie rescue but
rescue is such a like i rescued a pet
like you hit
i didn't carry a baby out of a burning
building i picked up a gross pig because
no one else would pick it up and then
i'm so codependent
and uh you did hide it in luggage and
smuggled in a hotel i did do that don't
say the name of the hotel because that
is
i believe that is a illegal what i did
so this was when i got him he was like
the littlest tiniest
you know scrubbiest little he was a
starved uh uh
a product a victim of how about that the
micro pig industry i can't believe you
have these photos of us
i do i stop it and look this is him when
he finally started being able to walk
a little bit and this is him um at my
house on my couch i mean is that the
cutest thing you've ever seen him
jumping on the couch
pigs are so emotional and they're so
engaging
and they're so smart what is it the
third smartest animal or maybe the
second smarter the dogs and they have
the emotional intelligence of toddlers
so hanging out with him like was so
sweet look how he would find little
places to hide
people have the emotional intelligence
of toddlers you know what you know what
honestly pigs might be
gonna be smarter so i got so obsessed
with this pig i used to have to take him
to the vet every night at like two in
the morning because he had pneumonia his
temperature was 104 degrees like he was
just like dying and i didn't know how to
help him and most vets have no idea what
to do with pigs because
no one pays money to keep pigs alive so
we
drove this pig from california to best
drop texas
in on a rainy day two years ago to get
him to this pig rescue where they were
going to take care of him and they knew
what to do
that's us how cute that's him
being carried that's this is the first
time i went to central tech texas pig
rescue
and this is when i had to leave him it
was so sad
look so this is how big he was by the
time i dropped it yeah look how much
bigger look how much bigger he is
because i fed him
and he would just roll over and let me
scratch him love pig
i'm obsessed so obsessed he's the cutest
thing ever
so we went back to black toenail polish
we went back for a very emotional
reunion where i got to see my pig again
for the first time he's
so big he's such a good boy that's him
right there but i am going to be honest
with you guys
i pictured that he was going to like run
up to me and like like jump into my arms
and be like
whitney like we had this incredible bond
and he kind of didn't recognize me at
all
he was like he didn't recognize me at
all and well it wasn't he's a
naturally a scared pig hasn't seen me in
too much it was more like there was a
lot going on well your outfit could also
be jarring
that isn't i wore an outfit of myself
covered in pictures she was like he was
like wow wearing my trauma back in front
of me
thanks you're gonna dig the pads up when
i couldn't move
i had a full outfit planned out to where
oh it's making me emotional just talking
about it
and he did not recognize me which is
okay
because they pulled me aside because i'm
so emotional with animals
oh my god and they pulled me aside and
they were like no it's not your fault
he's just
he's got a lot of brain damage it's not
your fault he's a pig
um i know it wasn't even he was big and
then he was like i mean
the pig had a 140 degree temperature for
six months i mean
this thing's a vegetable i mean it's
brands and eggs
we're happy to keep feeding them and
we're so excited you're coming to visit
him but
i just like in my head it was like such
an am going to be such an emotional
reunion and it was sort of me being like
hey like trying to give him a character
all the other pigs are doing math
they're playing pictionary you're a
pig's like hey all the other pigs were
super happy to see
but to be fair could you imagine someone
coming up to you wearing a full outfit
of pictures of you
that would be upsetting that would be
jarring you like what the hell oh god
but the work they do is so amazing this
is me i finally kind of was able to like
spend some time with him and get close
to him but it was like it was just
i had projected so much into it so then
we saw these other pigs and scratched
all these other pigs bellies
and it was it ended up being so then i
just saw other pigs and i like
there was there was an alcohol i guess
the fact that i'm crying is so pathetic
oh my goodness i love what they do so
much
that we decided to do a little a little
challenge here we decided to
raise money we did an ig live um in a
place where no one had wifi i mean
more things could not have gone wrong if
you scripted it out but we did
uh this uh big thing where i went into
the pig
the the what do you oh this is called
this is a pig wallow
if i raised a thousand dollars on ig
live i said i would sit in this pig
wallow
um look at that sat all the way in
went in raised the thousand dollars
emily saw me in the bog
and was disgusted and frankly annoyed
frustrated
disappointed and then i just like a
little light bulb went off in her head
at her she has these like um sparks of
entrepreneurial genius where she knows
she can get
cash fast in by uh manipulating me
because she knows what i value
and so she just yells for five grand
i'll run in
and i was like okay that's the easiest
check i've ever written
and then i said okay so if you run in
here because as soon as she said it and
i said yes she had one of those little
moments like remember when she was
offered seventy five hundred dollars to
give herself a wedgie and she didn't
wait to get on instagram but you need to
come see explain that i'm an
inside kid okay so that's emily's whole
thing she doesn't even let my dogs lick
her
it's gross it's gross because she thinks
that's gross and
uh what did you tell your uh child
because i was like well you played
outside as a kid right i didn't
why not i'm an inside kid she told her
teacher during recess that i was an
inside kid
i got to stay inside and paint while the
other kids played
and i was like didn't you play sports no
why not i was on the student government
association
you are the ga you were the type of kid
i would have beaten up
when i was in high school and so she
said that i was like okay
i saw her deliberate after she said for
five thousand dollars i'll run in there
i was like okay
i will double it for central texas pig
rescue because they need to barn really
badly and they're moving to a new space
and have new pigs right
so if you jump in here not only are you
making money to get the car that you
need
to buy you're also gonna you know
i'm helping pigs you're helping pigs so
this is i'm i don't think i've ever
laughed so hard i'm gonna try to just
play this video in its entirety and then
we'll go back through it
and discuss i told emily no she said for
five thousand dollars i'll run in
because emily needs herself
a car so emily if you come in
you will get that money and and i will
match it to central texas pig rescue woo
that five grand is gonna buy them a barn
and emily a camry
okay come on emily
oh
get out this is where i lived
[Laughter]
oh
go forward okay okay you got it
i can't get out i really can't
is
that was pretty easy i i think it's
important to
acknowledge that emily's first line in
the bog
was my band-aids
and then by the way the best is when she
fell on her hands she started trying to
clean her hands off with the bog mud she
was
literally cleaning her hands like out
damn spa the best part of this video is
you stopping to wipe your own eye
well i i had mud in my eye you're like
can you hold oh
god i started first of all is my shirt
she was wearing
so that made that made it a little less
weird but i i was trying to help her but
she splattered mud in my eye
and so i was like had like pirate
strength where i was only using one eye
and then i was like if i
can just clean this off i can get her
out of this box and then it took a good
40 or so minutes to get her boots off oh
my god
well i don't know he was most scared
okay so that's there was a guy that
wanted
emily to send him a picture of her with
a wedgie uh for 7 500
so i just did it right now so you can
demo it to me
yeah people want me to do stuff for them
on my instagram can you tell whitney can
you help me do this
you're over here just can you give a
wedgie how about you right now
so this is like trying to get your boots
off it's actually not a bit
look at what's coming out
i was holding on without all my might
with all my mind
on me after all that that would be the
grossest part of this
okay they were surprised if you farted
and that liquid came out
the number of people who had to get
involved to get off
one boot of emily's body i had scrapes
on the insides of my arms from holding
up
look at that look how long did you think
this helpful wait look how hard
you hug this pillar like abrasion
like you're a um a civil war wife and
your
husband just came home from war or he's
leaving you're trying to pull her off
can you guys help like what would i what
could i've done better in this situation
you're doing great oh the
suck i mean it was
a nightmare you probably saw that sock
somewhere okay so grace
grace is the winner of the central texas
pig rescue
uh visit excuse me
you earned you earned you were a victim
so grace said when um we're going to the
the pig
rescue place um this is grace's theory
on why pigs need to be rescued
okay just tell them tell them what you
said about
pigs they can't they can't like lift
their necks so they've never seen the
stars
i used to have that problem but now
everyone everyone at the big rescue was
like what
like what's happening did this girl win
a contest
to come to central texas they were like
the pigs can lay down and roll over oh
that's what they said to her they're
like
um because they sensed how much it hurt
her they like
i was like didn't want to burst or
bubble but at the same time like no no
they can lay down and
and when they're sideways they see stars
honey it's fine
and like grace i guess grace thought we
were gonna go like lift them up so
they're like do you want a sticker
you want a sticker before you go like we
were just gonna go around lifting up
500 pound pigs just so they can see the
stars
but that is such a sweet i mean how cute
is that um
okay so now we we uh before we get to
tim tellin
i'm gonna tell you that i snapped in
texas and this is something that happens
often and will continue to happen i
found out about the zoo it's called the
capital of texas zoo also a stupid name
were you alone for this
i was alone what were you wearing
because that's the best you're about to
treat you're about to see
because i videoed the entire thing uh
y'all know i am known for storming into
fucked up anywhere really just pick a
place cvs
the capital now back to the animals look
at this lion just in this
mud pit alone that's so sad and then
this white
tiger is here this is really what grinds
my gears because you've heard me rant
about this there's no such thing as a
white tiger now it's
all inbreeding and they all the reason
they have cross eyes is most of them
have
extra chromosomes because they've inbred
so much so whenever you see a white
tiger
that means they're breeding daughters
and fathers brothers and sisters it's
always some kind of inbreeding going on
so i saw that white tiger and i was like
i don't like this one bit i'm gonna go
ruin my
day and this tiger in this little cage
right here
is just despicable and disgusting so i
saw these pictures and i was like uh oh
mommy's gotta turn around
ah whitney's grumpy so i went in to take
photos uh
and video for myself i went in there
were basically 13 year olds running the
zoo this is not this is not a joke
so these are the photos that i first as
i was going in
okay it's like okay the animals are
eating dog food
like this is very bad news if someone's
feeding animals dog food
uh and especially if they're not dogs
and i went in
there was exactly this is not a yeah so
this is a
i don't want to blow up this person's
spot so i'm just showing the site this
girl was probably what
13 years old and she's giving these
animals dog food
around apex predators and i'm like none
of this feels right it just doesn't feel
right it doesn't track for me
why are we giving friskies to this fancy
feast
it's not okay everything that's going on
so
i then kept mushrooms in that bucket
don't get me fucking started on how
disgusting this place was and
not disgusting as in like this is gross
i mean like in like actual animal abuse
so i went around i was mostly looking
for the white tiger because it was
missing
and there had been a big freeze in texas
and he either sold it or something and
so
i'm i'm looking for the white tiger i go
into the the the lion
this is the lion enclosure do you see
right over here the baby in the back
right here so there's a baby cub in the
back in a separate
cage already abused because they're not
allowing the mother to be with the baby
i go see the bears which these are the
ones that are here
yes these are the ones that are asiatic
black bears that are used
for that uh their gallbladders it's like
a huge animal
trafficking thing where um uh there's
illegal hunting for it but that's they
put bears and boxes and they take their
gallbladders out it's like a folk
chinese medicine thing
how do you not know this i'm i'm
informing this is so exciting
i didn't even know bears went in the
attic yeah so i'm looking at these two
asiatic bears that are
atheistic that are in the tiniest
they're basically in
an attic at the moment it's like a tiny
enclosure and
none of them have none of them have
water
which is illegal and there's no food or
water or shade which is all illegal so i
go in
gun's blazing i'm like i would like to
speak to the manager
hard and uh did not did not go great
and i just thought you guys should see
the kind of undercover crazy shit i do
now undercover blatantly in front of
them no but now yeah
well it was undercover at first because
i didn't know if the guy was there so i
needed to get get the footage before we
got an altercation because he
technically he could call the police and
say i'm trespassing even though i did
pay
and all these people have guns and
they're really nasty and violent it's
obviously psychopaths
so i got all my footage first uploaded
to the cloud in case this guy want to
cue me
and then this is me this the two bears
no water
this is me talking to this person i just
think the audio is so funny i mean
trying to reason with a 13 year old i
like the 13 years like what are you
talking about would you like the owner's
phone number oh none
so so my i'm happy to talk to the owner
it's not going to go well and he knows
better than us
so so what's the plan and i also want to
know where the white tiger is
and um yeah i don't work with the big
cats at all
i know this isn't your fault i'm not
sure i'm not trying to upset you i'm
just there so there's no protocol in
place when he's gone
for y'all to just be able to refill the
water well really leaning into y'all
trying to be like i'm from texas this
girl's like i have to go to hot topic at
like three o'clock
and you're really she's like we have a
concert and i'm just trying to afford my
ticket she's like i need to have a party
to go make slime with my friends in a
minute
i was without him refill that oh okay
yeah
okay and then because you see they're
trying to get in because they're hot
yeah and they can overheat and have
heart attacks happens all the time
so he just doesn't care well he
he says to you know fill up as much
we've been
so many things been happening today but
yeah fill it up as much as possible i
i don't know this is the behavior of
incredibly stressed out animals yeah
like i mean it was still being all my
jobs do you want someone else's phone
number
do you want to call anybody else who
would you like to speak to this is what
i call
when being a karen is good okay
definitely a karen because this makes
sense i'm being a full karen but about
something positive i feel like all the
karen's out there if they could just use
it to like
protect animals protect kids like do
something good
it could change the world okay so gonna
use a coupon i haven't seen these videos
but this is just me talking to the
camera because i was like oh i'm gonna
make like a whole thing
she's vlogging i'm fully vlogging and
trying to take this motherfucker down
which will happen
uh but i don't even know what i say here
but it's gonna be embarrassing because
i'm so fucking serious
you need somebody explain to me where
the bears water is
even though this enclosure is already
fucking small
this is it this is when aunt whitney
loses her shit
this is the exact time she loses her
fucking mind more on that later and now
there's a little announcements page so
that i don't have to say all the
announcements anymore and be super
boring and annoyed and mispronounce
everything and get the dates wrong
it's written right there learn to read
look at that new merch you can speak to
that please
new merch june 4th yeah this is a
smaller collection than we normally
launch but it means we're fancy
yes it is a much um it's just a nicer
it's
nicer quality nicer everything nicer
graphics yeah we just really tried to
improve it and it is
really fun it had a really it's very
it's a big swing like it's very
artistically
like in your face it was all it was like
us you'll like it i think you guys
really like it but we took a lot of your
notes took all your notes we did take
all your notes we're going to baltimore
uh june 10th through 12th okay so
remember to go to beta tour
we booked this when we never thought we
would do comedy again and we're like
doing comedy to cars we're like let's do
it together and like
you know we're trauma bonding there's
still one more date left in reno nevada
uh july 23rd and it's just so great
shows too i know they were a blast but
it's just so funny that we're like
haven't seen it because when we get
outside in the rain in like
close to new york whatever i think that
was cape cod oh no that was connecticut
that was connecticut oh that was the
most fun and then um
las vegas i'm coming to the mirage
saturday uh august 7th so beat the heat
beat the heat come see the comedy show i
know that's a fancy venue
so now uh it's time for
a tim dillon interview which feel is
very much like
like a rematch from when he was here
oh you fought him yes fought him because
most of the people that he was telling
me i wasn't cool enough because i didn't
know them david dobrik and all these
people most of them are canceled now
also children also children what do you
mean right they're young
huh they're kids right david doberger in
them how are they i don't know
oh i don't know i cuz if i knew
that'd be bad oh that was a trick and
you won don't write elephants ladies and
gentlemen here's tim
slate whitney cummings two 1 5 3
4. she just likes to make fun of me at
every turn
at the podcast awards they're like can
you do a soundtrack and i was like hi
i'm whitney coming she's like
the podcast awards the ambience which by
the way had sound issues the whole time
ah market margaret
i have margaret uh let me know when
yeah see i'm like to micromanage this
because i have a set of skills that
are no longer needed by anyone right
which is
directing creating television shows
making movies
yeah i know turn market no one even says
that anymore right well you did the
godfather right right
making movies i played the horse dead
horse in the bathroom yeah
that was my horse uh and i know how to
do all these things that nobody respects
anymore
and it's like i'm i'm i'm well turned
this podcast into like an episode of
frasier
like you've turned it like the slating
and the like let's start
but what takes all the fun and
spontaneity out of it
and it makes it uh into something it's
not but it's interesting yeah that's
what i do with relationships as well
everything has to be over controlled to
the point of having absolutely no
serendipitous fun or anything because
none of it matters no matter how much
magic you catch it does not matter
if the sound isn't good or if it's not
in focus right i
did an independent movie where i put my
own money into it we
shot 14 days like the whole day like
that's a not a lot of time to do a
feature movie
like was giving my whole life and we go
into post
half of the shots are out of focus
people were like whitney's crazy she's
micromanaging she's controlling like can
we just
check and make sure it's in focus
everyone's like oh fucking women bitches
be crazy
get in there half of it's out of focus
and uh
uh there's extras in the back there's
one remember in the bookstore scene
there's a bookstore scene at the end
i had to like pay my own money like rent
out this bookstore shooting the scene
and i kept saying i was like there's
because i was on camera i was like
there's a weird action in the background
wearing like pajamas i'm telling you
it's weird and i was like when you just
calm down just
stop fucking micromanaging everyone we
get into post it fully looks like
someone in a kkk hood right it is a long
t-shirt that looks like
uh uh kkk garb we have to send it to
india
it costs 8 000 to remove it frame by
frame
but i'm i micromanage
well you know uh this is not that
okay tell okay yeah tim has decided that
i am
profoundly eternally wrong on pretty
much everything
profoundly okay but eternity i've never
said you were profoundly
okay anything you have the last time you
were on yeah the good for you podcast
you spent two hours eviscerating me
for uh uh being irrelevant and
uh what i still makes me laugh an old
goat
that knows nothing about the hot new
kids everyone that you bragged about
has either uh is either on trial
uh who was it oh yeah the tick tock it
was it wasn't david dobrik
that you were into at the time no i was
saying that you
were you were disconnected
from what was going on thank god and you
were talking about
uh me being a judge on the masked
dancer i believe you were saying that
the career
goals that i should have involved
being a judge on the math dancer and i
was saying no
i don't want to do that and you were
aghast at
the idea that someone would maybe want
to skip that part
of this business let me ask you a
question what would be more
more hilarious than you as a judge on
the mazda dancer
um fun banter with a hostess at a
restaurant
i mean literally anything else but you
get to do it all
like that's my thing is like take the
money here's the thing you
don't get to do it all this is the
fallacy okay you do not get to do it all
who is doing it
all that's a great question that's what
i want to know that's a great who
who we still respect sure nobody's doing
it all
tiffany haddish kind of does it all
where's her podcast i know well that's a
good thing but i mean i'm just saying
she needs one yeah yeah yeah yeah she
doesn't need one yes you gotta pick she
doesn't need it
do two things well right and a third
thing every now and then for a money
grab my thing is more
uh don't cut off your opportunity
for the fun money grabs if someone comes
to you and is like hey
for half a million dollars you want to
do four episodes of the mass dancer all
in one day
just do it and this this is what i love
about you is that you live a life
you live an interesting life so you can
tell interesting stories go do it if
anything because your podcast will get
better because you'll be able to tell
stories about it
the reason why this is a false choice is
because i am not being asked
to i'm not being asked to charge you
missed answer right
because i would when i got to set by the
way i never said you should do that i
had just done it you did it and people
can watch it
and make their own decisions you know i
was on drugs that entire time
if i was judging the best answer i would
stop in the middle of it and go
why are we here why are we doing this
what is wrong what is so deeply wrong
with all of us that is why they don't
ask me to do it
mass dance i mean look there is
something to be said for
mass distraction and visual anesthesia
and we had it for a while and it was
great art right you are
great shows right we had amazing
television we still do have some really
great shows
we had great movies that's mass
distraction
i don't know why mass distraction has to
be somebody dressed up like a tiger
dancing on television and then you
quizzing them
about what reality show they could have
been on and trying to figure out their
identity here's what i'll say
it is that makes me go i'm not
distracted anymore
i want to join a militia instead of
oh this was a good episode of er i go
this is dumb they're bombing every
country in the world they're taking all
of our money and they're not even giving
us
you know my friend nick mullen would
always say like just give us good movies
yeah okay if you're gonna let epstein
just lane run the whole
just can you give us fucking tommy boy
we're gonna get back to that in a second
but who would be higher on the list than
me
to play just lane maxwell in a
mini-series
name one person who'd be better at it a
better actress or just a better pick
um i don't know maybe like
like of course julian accent
can you do it of course can you do a
british accent
because it's proper it's not it's not is
it
no that's cockney that's southern that
was not cocktail that was nothing
southern is cockney you know what i
can't then there's northern which is
manchester liverpool
but just lane i think was it it was sort
of slow it's troll
it
it's very young they're very young but
everybody's having fun the teaser d's
she's barely 16 you're lovely now you're
going
i'm auditioning yeah but it's bad you
loved this
young i don't know how to say pussy with
an english accent
what you but just lane would never say
that oh good
point so you have to understand you're
just being a little naughty weren't you
why aren't you being a little oh jeffrey
bill and hillary were being a little
naughty
and it's just kind of a soft billy billy
it's a soft
regal kind of british accent it's not
that excuse me hold for the
hold for the boat we're yeah we forgot
to contextualize that we are
on lake austin and there are
um frat frats on boats behind us
it's a softer party and it's not like a
cockney accent where it's you're
imagining it when she's like we got all
these kids we fuck in the house
that's nice she would they would have
gotten busted away sooner if that was
her actually exactly the
key to that racket was her escoda and
saint
john's suits horrible woman but you got
to imagine a great dinner party guest
dude no one can be that damaging
and uh it's not a little bit of fun for
that long and not be
a charmer quite here let this episode be
in
our defensive lane max no but that is
the that to me
is the conversation nobody will have
which is that no one
gets away with stuff that long if
they're not a little charming or
entertaining or beguiling
well it's a hard point to make i take it
and i agree with it i think she was the
key to his whole racket
it's a tough she was he was a pimp
yeah she was the person they were like
oh that's his that's his beautiful wife
he's dating
that is the key to predators is they're
married or or aligned
with someone that is their same age even
older than them and you go well he's
married to her he
that's so cool he's with someone his age
meanwhile
he's getting jerked off by children uh
in you know coconut grove
or wherever right so it's like she
throws you off because you see that guy
apart and you're like he's a fucking
pervert and then you're like
wait he's with her and she's true she's
got some questions she's very good
she's got some crow's feet she's got she
looks like she you know
uh has some some of those she she
doesn't even get her face done like he's
not shallow at all i'm wrong i'm the
asshole i judged him yes
meanwhile you know and he's just tearing
through
dastardly activity behind closed doors
that to me is the whole thing well it's
like bill and hillary clinton right so
you're like oh he's with this strong
woman who's like a real you know she's
not a homemaker she's out there she's
got a career
and he can handle that and isn't that
great
and how modern and how progressive and
everything and all the articles in the
90s
you know what it is yeah he wants to
date an equal that's what we say
he wants an equal and in the 90s that
was the the the rationale or that was
the whole
you know um you know the kind of uh
the inertia that moved their campaign
forward was that
it was the inevitability of the of the
progressive modern change this is a
strong woman
yeah and but what it really was was
partners uh he could be with some
thought
and he's not what was great is that
recently there was a quote from the gail
sheehy biography of hillary
where after lewinsky she didn't talk to
him for a matter of months
and then only started talking to him
again when she called him
and uh told him to bomb syria so
that's a real marriage so i
am a lo i am fascinated with those old
school relationships
where it's like we're a business and
i've heard a lot i know a lot of these
couples in hollywood and the whole thing
is
do whatever the fuck you want to do i
don't want to fuck you you don't want to
fuck me
right we don't have a prenup just don't
embarrass me that's the deal that's the
relationship i'm with robert pattinson
right now
it's uh who wanted to zoom they
wanted to do zoom with me and then
backed out of it
what i'm my agent because robert patrick
wants to do zoom with you and then
i was like okay sure and then uh i
emailed back and there was she was like
oh we'll figure it out lol but then
nothing
what do you think here's the problem
with i think it was just
hey i like your shirt you're in the
place where people just want to talk to
you
and you're like okay i'm not going on
weird dates like
i say money and the project up front
before i get on the phone with you and
waste so much my time
i would waste time listening to what he
had to say why not i bet he could help
me with my english uh
yeah perhaps i mean perhaps but those
you know like the obamas slept in
separate beds and the clintons were like
when you get to that level of work
that has to be done every day you can't
have a relationship
like my aunt no i know this is a
business you are both
i actually i used to work on a i was
doing a joke for a while
before uh when hillary was running
uh this was before four so this must
have been what 12 years ago i was
in napa which is a super conservative
part of the country i didn't really know
that
and i went on stage and i said something
about like oh my god we could have a
female president it's still the chance
of her winning at that time were
incredibly slight this is the first time
she ran
and i was doing jokes about having a
female president and there were a lot of
like kind of unoriginal jokes going
around like
when she's on her period watch out she's
gonna start a war like people like had
already done shit
about female president stuff but i was
trying to do one that was like
the first female president if we have
the first female president uh
we're gonna have to like put in the a
contract that she's
not sucking her husband's like he has to
get sex workers during the time she's
president because like
no world leader can know she's sucking
like that's the least
regal act you can do like just everyone
needs to know so they're not sitting in
meetings being like
did she have her head in someone's
fucking lap last night just to let
everyone know she's not
fucking for that four years it has to be
part of it because it's just too
degrading you can't respect
and um and i was in napa doing a joke in
that area
and someone yelled at me
uh know your demographic and i was like
huh
yeah and then like uh it's the only time
i've ever done stand-up where a fight
broke out in the audience and i couldn't
see what was going on
like people were like i just saw like
wrestling and people
i didn't realize how sort of
conservative that area
i agree with the person who yelled that
but because it's a wine
it's people are trying to get wine drunk
in napa and they don't need you
showing up and telling them about uh
little miss president but it wasn't
it wasn't a it wasn't a charged
political joke
it was like i was also people i was
talking about ross perot i was talking
and then i was like i am just not going
to do political life
yourself now a little bit you're like i
was doing my truman bit
and then i broke into what if we had a
lady in there and i got you know
i was doing my old i was not doing a
rasp
but i did thomas jefferson chunk
and then i uh i forget you've been in
the business literally
since the dawn of time people forget
this this isn't
dye this is her natural hair she's been
in the business
so long that she can throw out that she
was doing ross perot material
i was trying to think of no because then
i was like dan quayle i
i do so little politics growing up and
and spending most of my time in dc you
get so fucking sick of politics that i
can't even like follow it to me it's
just because it's
a shitty city because people only talk
about politics new york
people talk about real estate and food
this is true
people are obsessed with where you live
how you got the apartment what does it
look like how many square feet in new
york
in new york everything in new york is
real estate because it's eight and a
half miles by two miles
so people are every position that people
end up being in that everybody's
fascinated by like
there's no other city every other city
you sit down you go i got an apartment
they go where is it by the park you go
great good great
in new york it's how did you get it what
was the deal yes who
it's an obsession with new york because
getting a good deal
is what everybody's into and they love
food in new york because there are so
many restaurants and there's so many
things where people will get into like
loud and angry debates about cheesecake
yeah or whatever
and that's what new york talks about it
like money real estate food
dc is only politics and la is only the
entertainment business and mid traffic
when you arrive and now it's homeless
people but it used to just be
it used to be like so how did you get
here right and then you for the first 20
minutes you talk about how you got
in because it's nothing yep no one talks
about anything
because there's nothing to talk about
except
the tech people are moving here and
people either love it or hate it
it's a city without an identity i love
that you're zero furious
that austin is getting highly populated
and more corporate because you've talked
about it for the past year and made it
popular
this is your fault i've said nothing
about the city of austin texas
oh i won't go on record okay i'm not
go is a dump it is a dump
the city of austin texas is for people
that have not
made it in other cities like myself
like myself no it's true no it's true if
i
had the money to live in the pacific
palisades
which is now on fire i would be okay
i'm a loser but if ryan phillippe hadn't
been divorced by reese witherspoon he
would not be able to live in the
palisades that is also true
that is that is no prenup money that is
also correct but
he's not on the cruel intentions money
no
no he's not living off uh he's not
living off that dvr
what i'm saying is i am here as a loser
amongst
losers let's be quite honest about what
it is but you
come you came from new york i fucking
called this and
you you're right do not listen i don't
you were right about one thing
and it was that i should dye my hair no
it was that
you know austin i was gonna be very
unfulfilled which is fine because the
more
unfulfilled you are the funnier you are
so i'm fine with you continuously making
terrible mistakes and not listening man
and his wife love it but they like
street lights like they get excited if
they're street lights and
they get excited about you know it's
like it's like they're simple people
they're very simple people they like to
stare at the sun and wait for satan
to come and kill them because they grew
up in a cult
i like a little stimulation here and
there
you and i i don't get it here because
austin is a little
city there's two streets downtown where
everybody gets drunk and shoots each
other
and then in and around it is like people
that are like at coffee shops
angry and i'm like dummy of course
you're not making it you live here
you schmuck well austin look as someone
that is half from texas
i'm not coming for you i like jackson i
love dallas
i love houston well you're a you're i
like that you're a man of the finer
things in life
and you i mean i came here for dinner
you you show up with
pimento cheese in a plastic cup she said
we're having dinner
i thought she would have a meal she had
a frozen pizza she didn't know how to
cook there's nine assistants no one can
get a pizza
in the oven here she's got she's got
more
she's got more employees than the
pentagon and no one can get a pizza in
the oven
and then we're eating queso that's not
even warm and i had to smoke 19
cigarettes to fill myself up and by the
way
actually i i i kind of stalled on the
pizza i could have really asked someone
to do it but i looked down and it said
gluten-free and i was like we can't
we can't even bring that to today i look
in the refrigerator she's got almond
yogurt i mean it's like it's a it's uh
but the
the thing that fascinates me about you
is that you are obsessed with living the
life
of a billionaire uh uh
but like right now yes at all times
well life is short you will that's what
people don't realize life is over
already
that's right we're dying you know life
is over ready but what would
as someone who as i've known you you
have gotten nothing but
exponentially successful you're getting
what you wanted
and from what i gather you're uh more
dissatisfied
and cranky and i imagine i'll continue
to be up until the point where i'm eaten
by sharks
but i think this is a good thing howard
stern it's very much like howard turner
howard stern was
was so funny when he was like in a bad
marriage remember now everyone's like
he's just an amazing interview
but the angrier you are as a podcaster
comedian the better
well i'm also just confused that's all i
don't i'm i'm confused i
i i am making a go of it here for the
time that i what's the goal what was the
go
what's the go to do your podcast in
texas opposed i love it everyone's like
i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go save money on taxes you're
actually making money but half the
comedians that work came out here we're
making 20 grand a year
the idea for me more than you're paying
listen the money the money is big
but more than the money for me was it
was going to be new and i said to myself
i just quarantined for
a year in a place yes if i can get out
of this place and i can do something new
yeah that might be exciting i come to
find out it's not exciting
it's actually much worse and it's a
horrible city
without a soul it's a soulless city
that should be burned to the ground and
everyone that lives here should be
summarily executed or forced to be in a
north korean style labor camp
where they get skinnier and skinnier
until they simply disappear
and no one will remember them because no
one here can even make a fucking
documentary
about this dump it is not the live music
capital of america
it's three heroin addicts busking with
guitars there is zero talent here
in any capacity there's three
restaurants that are good and i've been
all of them twice already it is over
tech demons will come in and do what
they did to san fran they'll colonize
the outside of austin
and they'll invent chips to shove up
your ass and
and and the city of austin will be what
it has always been an
uninteresting dollar
but i do own a home here now
and i will say that i'm very dramatic it
is a great place to come and live
it's beautiful because the the the uh
appreciation of the home is important to
me
so i will say that comedically i'm very
dramatic but it is a great place to live
and a lot of people love it
and i love it and i want more people to
come
and keep buying the homes because it
it has these secret nooks and crannies
and you find
i didn't even know who i was until i
moved here but it is a beautiful
place so keep coming and buying i'm
doing
a bit on a comedy podcast but what i
really believe
is that it's a great place to raise a
family as long as they like you
are dull and never want to succeed
i am obsessed with the fact that so many
comedians followed a billionaire to
austin
listen he's not a billionaire by the way
he's he barely has money
secondly he's fine he's fine i run in
circles and people got a little more
than him
i love that all these comedians moved
out to austin be like i'm getting gonna
get on a show
he'd rather have someone they literally
brought homeless people here that are
talking about taxes you're like i'm
gonna save money on tech
it's like you live in a tent but also
also
he'd rather have someone that makes
bespoke knives on
than you right he's the piece now
there's people that are moving here that
have never been on the show they've
known him 16 years
they've never done the show they're just
they're just hoping that the people he's
flying in missed their flight if you
need someone last minute they're just
sitting in the parking lot like
gargoyle's just like maybe listen it's
going to be again
it'll all be great i don't know but it
just feels
i am not into it yeah well you
are you i it's also i like sociopaths
because they're funny
and i can make fun of them and austin
has a few of them
in the face if you make fun of them but
no it's just boring
it is boring here but you joe has a
family and he has the whole thing like i
was just like the idea of moving there
like you know without a family or
without having to like put a kid in
school i just was like you're just gonna
be in a
in a house in the in the hills alone
with your own thoughts all day this is
not gonna go well
no but i'm gonna travel a lot to la and
then eventually i'll remedy this but
it it's um it's an interesting thing
what have you learned about yourself
have you learned anything about yourself
i've learned a lot about austin
and i've learned a lot about that the
the craziness of la the insanity of it
uh was funny yeah and this is town is
really
not interesting this town's not that
funny people are happy
it's yeah it's classic it ain't funny
when you go to la it's a
great f like new york it's a great place
to live because
what was that that's rogan relax
he's calmed down he's strangling a bird
he's doing his nightly his nightly bird
and bird strangle now it is time for us
to take a break from the tim dillon
vitriol to talk about my favorite
liquid on the planet nope not that one
it's called june shine is there any
product that i use more in my life
like personally grace can come testify
that i is there do i drink anything
except june shine is the question
no june shine it's hard kombucha it's
what this one is a tall boy so it's what
six percent alcohol i like to say that
it's because i don't
do well on any other alcohols i don't
drink anything else because this is the
only product i have found that you can
drink have a little kick
relax a tiny bit a brighter buzz a
brighter buzz
and then not text your ex at midnight
trying to get back together it's all the
upsides of having something that loosens
you up without all the downsides
i call this my night night juice because
it puts all uh
my negative qualities to night night it
puts my alter ego to night night
and makes my uh my inner child go night
night so it stops going wow
and ruining my life and it should be
noted that if you're not like a big
kombucha drinker
this doesn't taste like what you use at
all
i'm not open for feedback right now
[Laughter]
last episode when giannis papas and mark
norman were on they were like ugh
kombucha we don't know what that is
that's like some la like hippie stuff
they drank it
you're like i'm actually drunk on these
commercials tipsy myself
yeah did you taste it taste as cold
taste that cold
that is that's a spicy kick because what
that is
i remember that does have a kick i know
and i get these sent to all my venues so
i have them um
in the refrigerator yeah they're now
addicted
everybody that i i'm just like just try
it i promise you will be obsessed with
it
and um hot uh info good for you is
making a can
we're getting our own can can for you
good for booch
we've worked out an exclusive deal for
good for you podcast listeners we've
received 20
off plus free shipping site-wide i
recommend trying one of their
best-selling variety packs it's a great
way to try all their delicious flavors
go to juneshine.com whitney or use
codewhitney at checkout to claim this
deal
that's i n j-u-n-e-s-h-i-n-e dot com
slash
whitney today's program is brought to
you by
athletic greens i'm gonna try to read
everything on the copy because there's
lots of important
statistics and information but i need to
speak from the heart on this one for a
minute
because remember emily when we were in
uh corsicana texas with monica aldama
from cheer and i was talking about
athletic greens the whole time
i tried to record it so we didn't have
to shoot this at i know
that i am healthier because i've been
having athletic greens and i put it in
water i carry them wherever i go it's a
little pouch
a vitamin powder that's every vitamin
and mineral in the world that you need
and it has improved my quality of life
this is true there's no jokes here folks
i mean profoundly one tasty soup of
athletic greens contains 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green foods
super blend and more that all work
together to fill the nutritional gaps in
your diet
increase energy focus and aid with
digestion and it supports a healthy
immune system can you stop talking in
your customer service voice just talking
your normal voice but i'm reading and
i know i love energy i love focus and i
love digestion
any time i go anywhere with emily we'll
be in the car she's like oh my god i
guess
and then like someone comes to open the
door from the hotel and she's like hey
my name is emily
and she turns into a disney feedback
emily's new boundary is i'm not
accepting feedback right now
i'm not okay you're fair okay guess what
let's talk about it in a minute
a foot away because we're shooting me my
eyes go too long and you know what
didn't even hurt thank you athletic
greens for helping me grow so much
muscle that it doesn't even hurt when
emily shoots me the dark gun
simply visit athletic greens.com whitney
and join health us
simply visit athleticgreens.com whitney
and join health experts athletes and
health conscious go-getters around the
world who make a daily commitment to
their health every day
again simply visit athleticgreens.com
whitney and get your free year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
today
i also do that in that way free you're a
vitamin d
yeah that's crazy by the way never have
to go outside again look at me
have you before well you know i have to
come here
so i am now drinking athletic greens
something i can honestly say tim dillon
has never done
i'm not a lake person i'm not a river
person i have to see the bottom
everyone's like let's go out on the lake
i'm like i don't if i cannot see the
bottom i'm not going in the body of
water
well listen i'm not
there's things in austin that are i'm
sure they're good
but i just i i i don't uh but you're
getting
but you're getting up a lot there's a
lot of comedy clubs here will you shut
up
no at least you're working your muscle
out immediately
every week and spending more than i'm
saying
because there's nothing to fucking do
except perform at a bar for some drunk
the fact that that'll change when joe
opens this club that'll change
but it is as of right now i and there's
a creek in the cave here and rebecca's
great
but i just i'm not i'm i'm just i hate
it here's what i was like
your genius is that you will
go like okay you're talented yeah no i
do feel like that
i was exaggerating um is that you will
go to a place
and you will not really participate in
the moment you're in because you are so
busy in your head
coming up with a rant about it like i
remember when you came to thanksgiving
you were just sitting in the corner
watching you do not participate you
don't really want to talk to anybody
well thanksgiving was a horribly
mismanaged nightmare
um you are not given entertaining in any
real way
uh it was stressful for the guests
um it was odd you were berating
some guy to ask him how he how much he
owed in taxes
jim jeffries walked in with his kid and
wife and like didn't even sit down
nobody knew what was going on it was
very
it was just disconcerting for many of us
and i was just processing that
moment of sheer and sounding because you
were doing like eagles with instagram
influencers
meanwhile jim jefferson all thought this
was a family event like
no one knew what was that but also there
was so much amazing food there and i i
think
i haven't as an adult hosted parties
that have expensive food and no one's
eating it and they're drug it your
friend's a drug addict so
they're not eating it because they're on
cocaine so they don't need to eat
i i spend so much time being like are
you gonna eat this i i was like
there's like people in the party putting
stuffing up their nose because they had
no idea how to eat through their mouth
i'm just saying yeah your friends are
drinking like cbd milkshakes and
i was trying to force people to eat all
the food i got i was the most
i'm the most annoying gas club enjoy it
enjoy the party try this
this is the way whitney holds something
she'll be like hello
it's like a manic mania as soon as you
walk in like the great socialites the
great host of our time
new evolution lily pulitzer breeze
through a room and like really
have a few bits of conversation when he
gets in deep with everybody
and it's absurd like you're supposed to
have like a very like
light touch with everyone and like hey
have you been where you been you went on
a vacation oh i love the cape and i'm
out and whitney's like what do you owe
in taxes right now
to people during dinner and it was so
crazy
i don't do small talk i only do big talk
so people come in like how's the weather
how's this i can't do that i'm like what
antidepressants are you on i think i
have a better one for you like i get so
i'm like let's talk about your ancestral
trauma somebody somebody like you have a
beautiful yard she goes what do you want
what do you want
what do you want out of this out of
everything people are like
dude it's so intense and it's so crazy
and then your friends are like a mixture
of like brilliant people and then
brain dead people so you have like very
smart people and then you have people
that like
like have autoimmune disorders they've
invented that are like in capes
yeah that are like in capes and don't
know where they are and everything's
like they do everything for a brand deal
and they're like pretending to have
lupus so it's a
strange mix of people i like to surround
myself with a very colorful
uh crew and i do not judge i'm not
elitist when it comes to like
intelligence i like
i like to like make a a party first of
all at that time it was really just
only people that were in uh homes
without other people because
and would get the test that would turn
into a negative
response a negative covenant was very
responsible
it was only anti-vaxxers
and so um so at the time those were
literally the only people that would go
out
yeah you know no one should really go
anywhere yeah all the same people said
no we're not going to do a thanksgiving
this year are you insane most
people are yeah
like stray cats to a bowl of milk
um they all think i'm famous i think
they're famous it's just shit
right when you introduce you to someone
you've never heard of who's got like 90
million instagram followers
and and it should be like they've got a
calendar and it's just like them with an
umbrella
and you're like what the fuck is going
on no they're super famous in india
right right do you want to sell things
like whitney will be like this is the
biggest influencer in kuala lumpur
and you go what why am i here but yeah
what's going on you
conversely were doing that shit with me
you made me feel so fucked i was like do
i need to get on tick tock and start
making like doing little noises and
faces on tick tock i mean you had a
minute where tick tockers were like your
main
future of your business i have dinner
with tick tockers
a few times um and i make fun of them
and they don't care because they're 19
and good looking so they don't care
that you're making fun of them which i
find refreshing yeah
yeah it's refreshing when someone goes
yeah i don't care you pig who cares what
you say
right and that's good yes yes you know
what i mean i had dinner with those same
tic tacs
they were looking at me i think they
thought i was joan rivers i don't even
know what was happening
i went to dinner with your you leave you
fucking leave la
and then i'm stuck there with a bunch of
non-comedians
and you're like i went with the great
michael gruen yes who i love he's great
but they're all
they have no idea who they don't know
what i do for like they don't know
anything about me and i'm just sitting
there
they didn't watch twin peaks the um
when when you by the way one of them
did try to hook up with me and which one
i'm not gonna say which one
okay but now what you should have done
it
no i don't i couldn't i mean this was
like 24.
it feels like if i'm gonna date a much
younger guy i have to wait until we're
out of the woods on this whole other
thing
no i don't think so yeah i think you go
you go you go in there and that's the
best thing for you would be to date a
tick tocker
i mean i don't know the the the i would
get it i'm saying to any and all
closeted tick tockers of age i will
absolutely date you
so let me how long did it take once you
got to austin to realize
15 minutes that you should should have
just listened to me
from the airport to my home i wanted to
kill myself here's what this is no
here's the reality it takes a while
to realize that it doesn't austin's an
nft
here's a doesn't it no no no no if you
guys got rid of someone that loves
austin
the first time i came here uh what a
couple years ago i was with kevin
christie we were doing the
the cap city or paramount or something
we come in we
two days to just be in austin and hang
out and we
we see all the pictures on instagram uh
keep austin weird i i love you
so much not loving austin that's you
enjoyed for two days no no we looked
through it and we were like this is two
blocks
like two blocks this is my favorite
story but we then the rest it was like
century city and we're like
it's two blocks on instagram it looked
like it was just coachella
all the time people that are brain
damaged and have been had
bad car accidents but i think but
you know that i got in the car with this
guy that picked me up from the airport
and he
was like are you any coming and i was
like yeah and he was like can you tell
your friends to stop fucking moving here
like they don't want you either yeah
they don't want us hey cool
[Laughter]
great what did you do by the way shut up
like how's he gonna live his job is
driving around he no he thinks that he
is in the second string militia for the
government
oh he's on oh but i like that guy that's
the armadillo guy yeah
i thought it was a blue haired person
who's like i want to shine no he hasn't
tell your friends to stop coming here
i have a one-man show one person is
someone that um
it's a body type that's just like a
giant pop belly like you can't see your
feet he
and he believes that the government when
we go to war is going to
call him in as the reserves
that's less of a crazy belief than the
idea that austin texas
is going to be the next big thing can i
tell you there used to be you know miami
in austin
a bunch of criminals moved to miami it's
like that's your algorithm no one ever
said that like no one's
everyone is saying no you don't read two
like two or three
it is literally the topic of
conversation i do
for the last several months by the way i
haven't invented this
i do not follow comedians that are
looking for
confirmation bias of the bad choice they
already made but dude this is the shit
this is the shit like i don't i'm like
okay
like let me to live like a person here
you have to have 40 million dollars
to live like the kind of life that you
need which is by the way because here's
what i would do with that money but
we're staying in a place kill everyone
in austin we're staying we're saying
never have to see anyone i'm not even
talking about buying a mansion
i mean that 40 million dollars would i
could invest in a chemical weapon
and decimate the entire city and then i
might enjoy it start building it up
again piece by piece but here's the
problem with you is that you
are so committed to being pissed off
which is why i think you're great at
what you do no no no no no no we are
we went we this we visited a 40 million
home we visited it and it
uh he uh uh first of all you think it's
a dump second of all
we go we go from the house to the lake
which is i don't know a thousand yards
or something because it's so vast and
beautiful and then you get up here like
this walk is too fucking long
you don't even want the mansion you want
what's going to happen
what i said and the way that i feel
is that austin's lovely place being on
the lake is beautiful
but you cannot compare it to being on
the ocean
in the freezing cold ocean in the
hamptons
after you get lyme disease and bitten by
500 mosquitoes
and get shot by seinfeld security the
hamptons
destroys austin in in every i am not
arguing that
in every region i just mean the hamptons
palm beach doesn't destroy austin
are you nuts palm beach is uh
what's good it's good about this
conversation is that the majority of
americans are unemployed so this is a
good conversation and a relatable one
for many people uh sitting at home right
now
talking about palm beach and hampton
they're really
excited i will say that for
uh uh for comedians
comedians have to live an interesting
life in order to stay interesting and a
lot of comedians they get successful
they get comfortable they have money
they stop going to grocery stores they
stop doing shit
they stop flying and they stop being
fucking funny and we look at so many
comedians that live in these big
fortresses
in malibu and they haven't done stand-up
in years and they're not fucking funny
anymore
and the i think the key to staying funny
is staying somewhat uncomfortable
so i think you coming here and being
this pissed off
i mean it's good don't you feel like
it's a little bit i'm not running away
i'm staying for a little bit but i gotta
be honest and i know me and like joe
obviously disagrees with me but i
understand that
but uh i just i just feel the way i feel
about it i could live here when i'm in
my 50s came from
when i'm 50 i can do it new york is the
greatest city in the world
okay yes it is what compares with new
york i don't disagree
but i think that if here's my deal about
new york
i love it was there most of my 20s tried
to
uh because i was with a dude in new york
uh rented for six months in um
chinatown basically i couldn't even
afford tribeca uh i mean i could it was
just like i can't
i can't give this is criminal this isn't
a criminal amount of money
right like you the fact that you're
charging me for this is great that
sounds cool this is an american
right to charge me for this amount of
space it is un-american it's largely
far and buyers yeah it's absolutely true
no but i realized i was spending eight
years
what's your beef i was spending eight
thousand dollars a month on a place that
was smaller
than my horse's stall but what and that
was 400.
my beef with new york is it's a bad deal
correct i'm ultimately about like this
is not a good deal
here's why it's not a bad i'm getting
scammed this is why it's not a bitch
every time i turn on the tub the thing
the toilet
fluvium would come out of the toilet and
then i call the plumber
he came and he goes well i can't fix
this and i was like well there's got to
be a way he goes
here's what he said to me he goes it's
new york the things that you don't
appreciate
the great food the great art the theater
the music the things you don't
care about love things you don't really
care about because you want pimento
cheese bread
these are the things why people live in
new york the sports
the nightlife the smell of urine okay
people like your people
do you realize that when you walk around
new york you get urine on your feet and
then you walk
into your apartment and you're putting
the urine of
all of new york city's urine on your
floor why are you afraid of urine
i i'm not what is this i've i've been
peed on i'll tell you
i'll tell you that right now okay i've
been peed on and i handled it great
good other people's urine
on my shoes and yeah actually there's
i understand what you're saying i at
least i'm paying eight thousand dollars
i have i
no city functions when it was at its
best agree don't disagree like new york
but i can go visit for a week and see
all the plays and see all the theater
and go see
blue man group and stomp and all the
greats right
but when i'm in new york my thing is if
you grew up without money
i think a lot of the people that love
new york so much grew up with
money and it's like fun for them to like
rough it in a small apartment and like
you know like live with nine people
because they i
everyone i know they grew up without
money they go to new york and they're
like
i this is i cannot spend eight thousand
dollars on this i grew up in this size
apartment it's not for everybody
why don't i why can't i why can't i go
to sleep at night
at midnight and not hear women screaming
outside and having to wonder like
do i need to call is that a murder i
don't know what i'm hearing
yeah well i i think many of those
women screaming are probably
pursuing their artistic endeavors which
i also disagree with
um i remember being in this apartment
and hearing screaming and i'd be like do
i go
do i go down there do i get uh do i like
do i help
and then at four in the morning all the
food trucks would come and deliver to
all the restaurants
so the baby the backing up is what you
hear four am
and they're like oh i'm gonna try to
take a nap like you can't i can't sleep
people
i understand that but people they they
discount a lot of that stuff because
there's benefits to being there right
right which is which i would i would
love to be able to live there was austin
let's be very honest
we're not comparing new york and austin
no we're not but we're saying this as a
city
it doesn't exist i mean it's not real
it's narnia it doesn't exist yeah you go
through the city you go this is not
anything
right right it's nothing it's a it's it
is it's a taco on the floor
it's a drunk frat a boy it's uh some of
someone's shooting
someone else and you i look because
i spent my summers in texas and i
remember because it is it's very vast
it's very spread out that's why people
like it
[Music]
for having for being here can i sue him
i think it was the right decision at the
time i think
at the time there were so few things
shooting and so few things happening
you came here you did the show a bunch
of times he talked about you moving here
i think that was an important moment
i love joan i wish it were and i and i
well i'm excited to work at his club
when he opens it but as of right now
just we're looking at it as a city
right and as a city i i'm disappointed
where i live it's more of a suburb
it's more of a suburb i live far away
you have to want it has all the problems
of the city with none of the benefits
the traffic the shitty the crime the
bullshit but you don't get anything good
out of it except fucking a barbecue
ribs who cares well my entire identity
this city is fucking
roasting pigs i also think that the
uh like the indie charm of austin
it's book i mean south africa it's just
rich kids who are now drug addicts
it's not indie charm it's like i grew up
rich i should invite them to my
thanksgiving
my parents would pay my rent and i'm
going to try to detox off all people
there used to be a there used to be a
ton of food trucks and you wait in line
and there was like you
like it was like fun and sexy but like
the grace and i went when we stopped on
the way to san antonio and i literally i
was such a loser i was like where are
the food trucks and i was like
i went to the reception the reason that
i go so hard at it is because now i have
to leave eventually
right so i know i know that i go so hard
this is like when you cheat on someone
you're dating just to know it's
l.a make sure it's over i will hate it
but where are you
okay so i also think comics we're always
going to be miserable where we are but
we get to be on tour
most of the i think that's the reason i
can live in l.a because i'm gone most of
the time that's
true touring and you have multiple
personalities that's right so one of
your personalities is upset and the
other one is speaking german why can't i
pick a good one to host this podcast why
do i keep
uh picking the i think you're doing good
you're doing fine yes
i i was thinking about it recently and i
listen to this women
i mean it's just like women that
masturbate with candles and stuff right
i mean it's just women that you tell
them like like is it crystal dead
like mustache removers this is the goop
of podcast
yeah this is like old women that sit
around with their baron childless
vaginas watching you
cackle is that not who's listening
is that not usually and dude you want to
fuck you and a bunch of horned dogs like
steve will do it for no who wants to
braille you out who's that
he's a massive star but what is milk
milk
what is that god you're like 68. it's a
fucking thing i don't you don't have to
be old to not
know what's going on pranksters and they
are content creators and they have like
a massive following
okay full send oh do you know anything
about full sense no
you don't know anything about full sand
no that means you're not sending fully
fi i have sent from you maybe to me
following the latest
ephemeral people that com they're pretty
damn fun
i'm sure they do like these crazy pranks
we're like let me know when they've
been famous for five years and haven't
been canceled then i'll learn who they
are i'm not gonna name the puppy
before someone's old tweets haven't
resurfaced yet i'm just saying he's very
interested he thinks you're an
attractive lady oh it's one person
no it's a team but one of them kind of
the breakout star
is it thinks you're attractive people
think i'm attracted to a guy named steve
will do it he gives
away teslas to people and he drinks like
a bottle of vodka
what's this he's a good guy how old is
he he's a good guy
what is it n-e-l-k yeah steve will do it
he like
steve he drinks a fish tank full of rom
do you know who
is grace is 25. do you
no one around you is 25. you've aged
these people horribly in the time
they're only allowed to watch my content
yeah i mean it's like
this guy oh let me see the guy with the
the sorry he went to youtube don't give
him a hit
don't give him a hit i don't want to
give him a hand yeah that guy this guy
oh he's pretty hot yeah but i'm
is he uh um on steroids
i don't know i don't think so clip this
it'll do well on the
channel it'll do well because it's the
uh it's in the algorithm you'll get in
there
now so what's his name steve will do it
but he will do it
do what uh drink and give away tesla so
this is fun they do fuck
it's like jackass it's like the new
jacksonville jackass thing they do like
fun things they go to like dubai
okay president trump okay
it's fun and what happened there did
hilarity ensue
not everything shakespeare in the park
okay it's funny they do funny shit
things are funny my thing is they'll
find an old man at like a grocery store
and they'll like fuck a girl on top of
him or something okay and then you feel
bad for him but then you realize he
probably did the my line massacre
but here's the thing in my day men did
all that shit
and they didn't film it yeah so
this is in shape the dude's in shape i'm
also
i'm also working on this theory that
everything that exists has already
existed in different iterations
is that your theory isn't that what are
you talking about
isn't that like kind of the theory of
relativity i'm just thinking about you
guy you guys are
acting like this is some like like
mind-blowing thing that guys do dumb
shit we've always had this
this is is this our generation's poly
shorts are you saying you should know
what it is they're like a massive force
on the internet
again i will know once they have been on
for five years
and there have been no rape videos or
accusations or old tweets
uh that are racist and i don't commit
until
they've survived five years in the
public eye okay that's a new idea i just
came up with
no bound that's a new boundary all right
you were like david dobrik's the guy and
i was like i don't know it doesn't smell
right
it doesn't smell right i was making a
the observation that was plain in front
of everyone's face which was
he at that time was running the internet
the guy had all the money sure i know
what that means
don't i know exactly what that means but
don't act like you had some like sick
sense that david dobrik was going to go
down for what he was yeah
i know exactly i know yes i've been i've
been around and as you know
i know how to pick people uh that have
squeaky clean paths well that's what i
was going to say
i was about to say you have all this
sick sense about i have good who's about
to get popped
you have you really i just like here's
what i'll say when it's a group of a
bunch of guys
what are the chances that if you have
nine dudes on a show one of them hasn't
fucked a girl who was drunk
why if it's one well that's what does
that mean everyone that's his odds
i'm just saying but i'm just saying
david dobrik of course if you have a
like a crew around you
like a like tur you've got everyone's
got a turtle everyone like as soon as
they get successful they have to have a
crew of people and i'm like
most of those guys are around you they
don't have any fucking talent they're
hanging out because they want to get the
leftovers at the end of the night but
we'll do it is one of the he's the main
one of the main guys he's like the main
guy
okay great all i see is this guy splits
his money between the six people in the
video
it's like a musician everyone's like a
musician all about money it's about the
fun of getting drunk and giving
people teslas yeah no anyone because
there's someone at home that
goes i don't have a tesla and he shows
up so let me tell you that the drives at
tesla
into their uh driveway and they can't
afford it that's what he does on camera
imagine what he does off camera
he's a good man why are we slandering
this man because i
am nice to start dating someone younger
i'm dating someone eight years younger
than me yeah but you need to date
someone younger who's famous you're
dating like some guy who's a
veterinarian who fingers cats all day
get a get oh we'll do it cougars mostly
yeah um but here's what i'll say first
of all they're not giving out teslas
these are given to them to give out i
don't think so i think they actually
they buy them and give them away okay so
because you're good people so walk me
through this they're giving someone a
tesla
which costs the person they're giving it
to money because they have to pay for
the insurance and is that a ga is that
again
those people like we can't afford to get
this tesla for maybe the person that's
getting it
has to go to the doctor and they can't
and they give them a test so he's got a
hundred million dollars but can't afford
accutane
he looks better now you're looking at
old photos of him
he looks better now okay still still go
to his instagram still still using that
pomade still committed to that side part
what is this what we're dealing with you
got to go to his instagram he's he's
better than that okay what is it steve
what
will do i've said it nine times okay but
that's not
dementia here well someone will you post
um the
tim's patreon uh on instagram so i can
then look him up on instagram you know
when you post something on a story and
if you go away from it it goes away
you know what i mean grace you know what
i mean just write
tim tim dillon's patreon what i'm in is
what i'm trying to do
is get you involved and then ben i'm
trying to promote your patreon
thank you uh patreon what is the um and
then the swipe up link is in the thing
uh the text thank you we need more uh
women
your patreon how do you approach your
patreon you
do actually how do you approach your
episodes that are not patreon versus
your patreon mentally when you go into
it
what's the different difference is that
the the show on youtube is more like a
tonight show thing because there's
it's
when she knocks she knocks she's invited
me here
to do a podcast inviting yourself and
somehow she doesn't own
and she's attacking my studio because
she's like an elitist
um this is her thoughts because there's
curtains stapled to a wall
uh unlike the great set of roseanne
you know unlike uh the diner of two
broke girls which was cinematic
um but designer won an emmy set designer
won an emmy that's great and where are
they now which i bet she had to sell on
ebay
i mean it's living with the bats under
the bridge but uh
so that's more of a visual show and then
the podcast i look at is more of an
old-school radio show it's not on camera
i like doing the patreon episodes
because they're they're
free from the constraints of being on
camera right i love audio as audio
and i argue for the supremacy of uh when
you listen howard you thought you were
in the room
and you watched me fell you were out of
it but i do love the youtube show too
they're slightly different but they're
very similar i also think that
that audio for whatever reason because
we're human beings and we get afraid to
speak publicly we get self-conscious
the level of bravery you can have when
you're not conscious of a camera
it's like a it's a different muscle like
when i'm doing something that's audio
only i'm like i'm so much better at this
because i'm not worried about lighting
and this and
the way i said that and like looking
like i'm listening you know like i'm i'm
there's always like background
noise critiquing me when i'm on camera
yeah but when it's just
audio there's an intimacy and there's an
authenticity that
i i feel like i can't always get on
camera unless i forget i'm on camera
yes you know that's what i said yeah and
then
it's a longer and more drawn out and
then so what is what is the
the plan because you know i strongly
believe that you should be doing
another another thing i'm going to tell
you to do that you're not going to
fucking do
just because i said it and if one of
your fucking agents and william morris
said it you'd do it in a heartbeat
i'm a cia okay whatever okay i'm no cia
is a very she got fired from william
no she was fat and now i have an agent
that's even fatter all of my
professionals are morbidly obese
i there's six fat people in los angeles
and they all
work for me or with me this is true
they work for me or with me in some
respect all right
we now take a second break in our
uplifting
program to talk about wallaby parker
warby parker i love warby i love the
name
i'm not entirely sure i could say it
more than twice in a row
but i'm kind of obsessed with it now
they uh are helping sponsor our podcast
which is wild i'm obsessed so what tell
me what we're doing today because i see
a box
we're gonna try on i mean if you can get
this out of my hands we're gonna try on
these warby parker glasses i shall just
hand them to you why because
because also they're incredibly
affordable i cannot stand this thing
this is why
glasses are always in 340 dollars now
and i'm going to have them for three
minutes
booty style glasses at great prices
right so they start at 95
yeah they send you this kit to try it at
home so you don't even have to go to the
eye doctor or go to the ice yeah or go
to
you you don't have to go you don't even
have to go to warby parker you just get
it at your house and you try them on
okay this is a game changer it's your
house you get to pick out what you want
to do a box of fives and then you can
try you have a little
you have like a little eyeglass store in
your house yep okay so i get to try them
all on
these i love oh these i like are you
jacqueline
okay so describe what they look like
like to people if you're listening
these are emerald green or no deep
forest green
it's a yes it's a large cat eye uh
deep forest and a little green lemonade
it's very jacqueline kennedy to me it
looks like you're gonna
look at yourself you are morning but you
have to be you can't cry because you're
too pretty
these i want to keep these are clear
rose like rose these are for this shirt
i love this
oh these are amazing but are they blue
light no i don't think oh i would make
these prescriptions
these are my favorite glasses i think
i've ever tried on glasses start at 95
including prescription lenses these are
clear roses look at this they have like
a blush
you do go with your shirt this is very
much like you're gonna go from the
library to the farm
i love this these are great for you guys
these are very written
these are very whitney type lashes they
are like a yeah like a like a
oh my god a pink tortoise they kind of
pull your cheekbone up when you wear
glasses like that those are good for you
these are like a plus especially with
like a
updo try warby parker's free home try on
program order five pairs of glasses to
try at home for free for five days
there's no obligation to buy
ships free and includes a prepaid return
shipping label try five pairs of glasses
at home for free at warbyparker.com
i couldn't pick so i'm doing this and
you can yeah oh like a spider
yeah like a a fly no the things that
what
a cinnamon they have lots of eyes oh
that's a good point okay a fly would
need
three triangles what were you thinking
of what are the things that it's like a
bunch of masks on a totem pole
i'm not choosing i'm taking them all
love it
manscape.com hey ladies get
funky no get the opposite of funky get
clean get smooth get hairless
yeah you be a sphinx you ladies are fine
you can have as much hair as you want
man it's your turn
to be uh to feel like a dolphin and
manscape just when you think manscape
has done it all here's another one like
just when you think they can't escape
any harder or better
they out do themselves yeah they're
gonna be taking skin off for long
there's a new lawn mower 4.0 i got to
say i didn't have many complaints
about the 3.0 i have the 3.0 it's in my
uh lovers dopp kit this is the manscape
3 and they even improved this one
impossible he liked
he liked it so much he stole it from me
and from the prop closet where we keep
our stuff
and put it in his doppel kit so the 4.0
is
also waterproof you can now turn the the
led light on and off if you don't need
it
so you can have like a disco ball
session disco ball a rave
a ball you can you can there's a new
multi-function
on off switch so you can engage travel
lock like they've improved it even more
wait
so that you don't it doesn't go off when
it's yeah because that one has a button
so sometimes when you put in your
manscape
oh you might you might hit it the button
button sounds like a vibration
you can have it all now get it 20 off
plus free shipping at manscape.com
whitney that's 20 percent off plus free
shipping at manscape.com whitney
it's dad bod season time to get smooth
why are you not shooting a documentary
of
everything that is going on right now
because it's
not that interesting i disagree of
course you do you
are getting this self-important
documentary
uh-huh would be the most grotesque
uh-huh thing in the world okay
this self-important self-indulgent
horseshoe the big
lie the big you just
the big lie over the last decade is that
people give a shit
about what comics do when they're not
being fucking funny
but they don't let me tell you why let
me tell you why though this obsession
with the process on the horseshit most
comedians when the documentary oh ben
got here ben did you get us food but
here's the show
i'm trying to give you a compliment yes
thank you most comedians when they're
not doing stand-up aren't that funny if
we've learned anything from podcasts
it's comedians during the day are not
that funny especially when they're not
with other
when comedians or other comedians
there's this thing of let's be as boring
as possible because no one wants to seem
corny like they're trying
right you know what i mean yeah so
that's my problem with a lot of podcasts
because i'm like we're just
bombing like sitting here like talking
about like mitzi shore who gives a fuck
and but you are one of the few comics
that's funny when you're not on stage
yeah well that's thanks but i still
don't think we need a
documentary about that
all i see is missed opportunities for
you and someone standing university you
can't
just just shove yourself down people i
do the two podcast episodes a week it's
two hours a week it's a lie
it's enough okay i'm gonna go on the
road and do live stream like people had
enough
i get sick of myself i don't disagree
but i think your kind of
fans want to see more of you
and because you because they're in jail
but okay fine don't listen to me let's
see how that fucking worked out for you
last time you didn't listen to me when
we were moving furniture out of your
fucking house
so you can get to austin as quickly as
possible so you can become a billionaire
it's not my fault that austin sucks and
nobody
wants a documentary about me doing a
podcast
as you said with curtin stapled to the
wall no one wants to watch you come
out in huge theaters and go from the
mercedes bus
to the theater to the pyrotechnics to
like no one wants to see
that they want to see this exact moment
in your career
where you are selling out six shows at
the wilbur
but then have to get in a rental camry
and then go back to a fucking doubletree
inn yeah but no one's doing that no
one's getting right you're making this
out to be
like i'm like tina turner like you're so
completely
gone i mean she's so
she's so completely on another planet
that like you don't even know what
you're even saying like
it's not number one both things are
equally uninteresting
the the only thing that's interesting is
the stage
or the podcast the behind the scenes
shit
this behind the music always sucked
no one cares because they were too
famous at the time
it only was good when they were on
heroin and dying no one cared oh look at
that my dad
how thought struggle so you don't
believe me you don't like heroes elita
springsteen
shut up so you're up you don't think
your own fans care about you that is a
that's dark no i cannot what i'm doing
that's dark
they're careful what i'm doing okay if
what i'm doing is good it's good
but they don't need the bullshit of like
no one cares you're not supposed to
shove yourself up people's heart you're
like
okay then why don't you go do an adam
sandler movie at netflix not shutting
yourself down because they said no but
that's not true that takes eight months
and then you put out
one one and a half hour thing and then
and and it's a movie
it's not a documentary okay here i am
in boston i'm at the rental car now
right
now i'm getting in it quick bit
joke isn't it all wendy's my parents
used to take me there
you go why are you why are you making
the shitty version of my good idea you
this is what
this is by the way this idea is horrific
it is a ha
it's actually worse than the masked
dancer i'd
much rather no but i do want you to be
in a sequined penguin suit in the entire
documentary
what i'm trying to say is someone that
has whatever my i
i have you know my friend nick always
says this
when uh uh there is a version of when
you're
one time we were looking at the stars
outside my house
and he was like oh that's the big dipper
and i was like okay i don't care and
he's like well that's ryan's belt and i
was like i don't care stop explaining
this
and he goes when you're an older person
you have an obligation to pass on
wisdom to the younger people and i can't
stop telling you it was like
it's like a tick it's like um wisdom
he's pointing out orion's belt
no i'm saying is that wisdom i'm just
telling you
when you know something you okay grace
and i were talking about this today
so i don't remember exactly what the
fuck it was but oh you're who was it
that couldn't use a fig
thing they didn't know how to use a
thing who was it
your one of your nieces or cousins
didn't know how to use the thing and i
said yes because wisdom skips a
generation
because we just talked about this they
showed the case of lupa why did i let
you drink these ciders
okay remember um when you because here's
my theory the older generation passes on
wisdom to the next generation and
they're like oh
we we've learned everything we don't
need to pass this to the next so the
third generation is dumb
yes what was it damn it it was something
about like uh
like an arcane oh my god it was putting
metal in the microwave putting metal in
the microwave
so she says that her friend what is that
her friend who is 25 put fucking metal
in the microwave and it was like yeah
no one told thought to tell her that
because it was so obvious that you
didn't need to pass that wisdom on and
then the wisdom was never passed
on yeah but telling me to make a
documentary
is dumb did you i mean it's just dumb
documentaries are good when they're
about pedophile cults political
corruption things like that the next
level in your
uh there's also this i've learned this
is just who i am i don't even give a
fuck anymore
i everything to me is a business and
it's like a it's like a
tick it's like i can't like i like
that's why i can't have hobbies because
i'm like oh i'm gonna knit and then i'm
like i need to sell these on etsy and i
need to go patent this like everything
has to turn into a business
i am watching you lose money by the day
by not tapping into the pathos
underneath your rage
but i think i'm earning money by not
taking your advice do you understand
i i would watch because here's the thing
how here's okay let me take another
angle with you
comedians jobs what is our job
i mean at this point whitney i don't
even know
our job is to what make people laugh
yes and what is laughter bodily function
no what is it ultimately what does it
come from what are you doing when you
make someone look
throat you you're surprising someone
you're surprised our job is to surprise
people right we're the fucking people
that jump out of the haunted house you
know our job is to
take them one way go there say the thing
no one else can say because that's what
everyone's like you can't say that's
like
the more you tell me not to say it the
more i have to say it because that's the
surprising thing to do our job is to
surprise people right
and sometimes and i think part of what
mark maron kind of did was
he he he did an emotional podcast it was
surprising to hear a comedian talk like
that's true that was groundbreaking
when he yeah yeah it was surprising to
hear someone that's like very
good talking about things not going well
which is what he did like
and most people lie about that and he
was on it to reveal
the the the pain and the anger and to
talk about his addiction that was
surprising because most comedians would
go up with the bravado and they'd be
like yeah
it was surprising forget about what you
think of it it was surprising i was
trying to go what's the most surprising
thing i can do
in this moment right when i'm on stage
what's the most surprising thing i can
say what's the most
i tell you that makes sense fuck you it
would be shocking
but you're saying what would be
surprising for me is to have like a
heartfelt
documentary it doesn't have to be
heartfelt i just want to go
watch you visit your mom that's all and
that you know what i'm saying
that's all i'm saying okay
you you can you can keep wearing
costumes and run around beverly hills
screaming
yes at meter maids in pumpkin costumes
you can keep doing that forever that
makes people happy you will
do very well instead of doing that i
should exploit my mother's mental
illness
for views that was your suggestion so
instead of doing a funny topical video
i should put cameras on my sick mother
and try to extract uh views from the
last few years she has on earth
i'm just saying if you put your mom in a
pumpkin costume i just feel like
you would not have to choose between
austin and l.a you could have helms
everywhere
and you know what it is and maybe i yes
maybe i'm wrong because the way you
talk about this helps us paint a picture
of it
and seeing it might demystify it but i
think
comedians are so inherently
i think people's lives are so inherently
interesting the minutia of our lives
they're not you're wrong but here's what
you're doing
there's absolutely
you mentioned shows that you liked when
we started what are the shows that
you're watching now
you just said there's great shows on tv
and then you mentioned the godfather
like i'm the fucking
ladies coming to see you today you're
the oldest woman i knew i was coming to
see you today
so i prepared with a documentary about
alienware nose
[Laughter]
that's but i other than that i haven't
okay okay the the the tougher you are
and the more you deflect this the more i
think it's going to be
a good documentary yeah that's a that's
a perfect way for a documentary to start
this is a fucking bad idea i don't want
to do this
and then you're just making me think you
should do it even more based on your
reaction because you're so afraid of
revealing yourself
in the cracks to the world no i think
it's a stupid idea that will bore people
i reveal myself all the time i have
hours of revelatory material here's what
i'll say
everyone knows everything about my life
the best comedians
should say this exact thing when people
think when people think that they're
interesting they never are but the
people like god that's boring that's
boring that's all i want to stand
say interesting shit but this idea of a
documentary is bananas did you see the
trixie mattel documentary
no okay but that's more interesting
trixie tells more interesting
i just think your fans like you like i
don't know there's just something going
on with what i'm trying to give you a
fucking compliment how much do you hate
yourself that you will not
at least go you're giving me a job give
me a project why haven't you no i'm
giving ben a project you will do nothing
you will do absolutely nothing
you will not lift a finger you have not
done i've never
seen you toil since i've known you you
show up
and then you scream at him and then he
edits together no one edits anything by
the way the show is
raw and well i mean the the the we are
editing out
when i quoted tony hinchcliffe from your
page yes we ready did you take that out
we've already
done that i just i'm too afraid to check
my phone we've already done that
though we did have to edit out one thing
from your patreon but the way you edit
your videos together
yeah online they're edited within like
25 minutes i'm like does this guy ever
get to go fuck his wife i mean
he's amazing um so i i just think
comedians right now need to think uh on
their own and stop doing what every
other comedian is doing
i do the road and then i do a special
and then i do a podcast it's like
who's gonna be the person that's like
okay this is this interesting thing
nobody's doing i always try to like
think about that even though
even if you don't like it what if i did
not let me like because let me throw an
idea at you now because i think that
that's opened up a lot of thoughts
and don't laugh i'm being dead serious
i'm being dead serious
what if do you remember the ice capades
like where they did disney on ice like
no comedian right now
is doing their life story on ice like
nobody's learned how to figure skate
no one can do it and it to me when i
look at a comic i want to see them
figure skate
on ice and tell the story of their life
okay i tonya won an oscar horrible movie
kevin hart decided to do uh
like black blades of glory i bet it
would be a fucking
home run great that would sell to
netflix yeah
business brain yeah black blades of
glory
you heard it here folks you heard it
here first
all right i love you but can i go eat no
i have more questions okay so you're
gonna move back to la
and one day oh this is what i really
wanted one day what is our
what we are such an odd friendship
yeah i think people in comedy are very
jealous of our friendship
yes perhaps
[Music]
are they you are i respect you you're
very successful
you work very hard you have a crazy work
ethic we both work a lot
that's the thing i love working
differently but we work a lot you know
what i love about you i feel like you
were the kid in improv class where they
like say anything from the audience and
they're like
down at the dmv and they'd be like hey i
read the dmv you're like that's fucking
dumb
no like yeah i never took an improv
class in my life
you will not go in any direction you
work a lot i work a lot there's there's
a bond between people that really enjoy
work and like to work
that's right because we have an
agreement we've eviscerated
their uh private lives in most of their
relationships because of that
and who've drained themselves of any
sense of happiness
and who've uh propelled themselves
forward by a commitment to this
thing this opaque addiction not a
commitment definitely an addiction
sense of finding meaning in this thing
of which ultimately there is none to be
found
uh and it's just two people hopelessly
walking along a road hoping and praying
that a car hits
them so that they don't have to continue
to wake up with the
with the uh need to continue to do this
i think there's some real common ground
i think that you and i have an agreement
that whenever we hang out we're either
plotting our next
move talking about investments or
monetizing our hangs
yeah i think that there's absolutely
nothing human that ever goes on
i agree like every time we hang out we
have an agreement like this
is brought to you by ridge wallet this
is brought to you by magic spoon like
there's no
um sort of uh like we should hang out
and talk not on camera like we're very
we get to the point
yeah well as that's our lives he's doing
this bullshit
who's your best friend ben okay but
okay but what do you mean what happens
when there's no pie left as you would
say
when i don't do the show anymore what
happens when his wife finally says
him or me no he makes money he fucks his
wife did he how long do you need to fuck
someone 12 hours
like what are you talking about you can
fuck every night
what is your dynamic with ben's wife is
there any tension
we have sex
they bring me into the bad ones come on
ben is truly the only thing i care about
on earth
it's it's very true man is the only
thing i care about on earth literally
there's a few people in this room and
you i would watch you all burn alive
if i knew that i could save ben i
wouldn't even
try to save any of you to save
women at the expense no ben is is my
brother and best friend i mean ben is
the only person
really in my life that i know will stay
there forever because we built the thing
from the ground
also he has stockholm syndrome what
choice does he have he is a beaten man
that you have blackballed in the
business and said anyone hired no he
could be getting you out of a tub i know
i get it
it would be much better it would be much
better i understand
but i don't think the fact that i work
with him
invalidates the friendship oh this kid
believed in me when no one believed me
you didn't agreed
uh when none of you knew who i was and
didn't really care
ben thought i was really funny yeah you
know what i mean yeah
and that's very important to me because
that's my whole life right right right
right
so i guess to me i we were kind of
talking about this earlier what happens
when
people are as a comedian when people
around you you got to surround yourself
with people that challenge you
i don't think ben does that um i do
think he does that i do he does it in
ways then
he does it in ways that i don't think
you you may realize
um he just came up to you and tried what
was i feel like i am helpful this is
my only goal in life is to be either
funny or useful
well you are one of those
no no no no challenging me i'm i don't
mean challenging i just want ben
to to i want us both to connect about
the things you need to say no to because
the next two years of your life is not
about what you say yes
it's about what you fucking say no to
and a lot of people that you think are
fancy are going to come up to you and
try to use you
to get their own clout and the answer
has to be most of your emails
don't even fucking check the emails at
this point but most of the answers are
no
and when i hear like this movie and sold
netflix and i'm like
why don't you fucking call me and run
this
by me i no one has failed in this
business
more than me yeah no no i
i number one i think
you're overestimating the interest in me
there's
there's not as much interest in me as
you think it comes from the fans which
is okay with me
right this business that you and many
others have devoted your life to
is not that interested in me and i am
not that interested in it
because it is not i agree i agree what
me and ben have done
is much cooler i agree much more
interesting and and much
funner i agree it's much more fun yeah
to do what me and this kid have done
yeah than what you guys had to do i
totally agree that's just a reality i
totally agree with you but there are
gonna be some other weird new
opportunities that
might serve you one out of uh that
you'll enjoy
you know what i mean i do and we'll run
them by you i do that's what you'd like
yeah we will run them by you i want no
decision made without me being we will
we will run the bike but it's unfair to
say that ben doesn't challenge
that was a job i agree i agree it's an
unfair thing to say
it's definitely unfair to say that i
came up in the 30s but we're joking
no no i know it's a joke but i think
that like what you
misunderstand no i don't really believe
that i'm not i'm not even thinking about
him i'm saying
this world that you're living in does
not exist
no but i don't live in that world i'm
podcasting every week i understand but
you still do because it's always about
that world coming in and then all the
opportunities
it's not real yeah yeah no it's puff the
magic dress by the way it's never been
real
it's everything we always did but it
isn't because you have a lot of money
and you did very well in it
but it's over now yeah it's over in
and that's but here's what i'll say what
it is
but easy for you to say because you have
been
pocket it is that i'm sorry i don't know
why i'm afraid
i know my way around here
the sitcom stage roseanne's rage
the sound here ma'am you have to leave
the building
i have 52 assistants
and i always i am persistent
that you do the masked dancer
but i mean look that was at a time okay
i
i believe i i came so
it was so fucking hard for me to get
whatever i got
i fought tooth and nail i come from the
place if you don't fucking say no to
anything you say yes to everything
because that producer produces something
else and is going to give you a job in
two years and you say yes to fucking
everything and you show up and you
tap dance and you're better than
everyone and you fucking prepare and you
say yes to the max dancer tomorrow
because then you're gonna get this like
i feel like i'm talking to elizabeth
holmes i'm just does anyone feel like
they're talking to you i'm just thinking
about bloody meters
you have to understand all you
motherfuckers that are going to cover me
in the comments with all the pizzas
i uh uh i would love peace can we eat
can you call my pizza restaurant that
sells babies to eat and get him a real
pizza
i mean i'm starving we only have adrena
chrome and anything there
is a bunch of mac and cheese in the
pantry do you want me no no no no
no he wants to stay miserable he doesn't
want you to solve the problem with mac
and cheese i was promised a meal
he wants to i don't want a bowl of mac
and cheese in the pantry
and he wants to go to his place is what
she does she offers a thing you get a
bastardized version of it
and when you don't and when you're not
thrilled with it she's like what about
thanksgiving dinner and you show up
she's like it's a horseshoe and you're
like what
she's like stay miserable then we can
make the
pizza no one wants to can we put the
pizza in there
i hired a 25 year old assistant they
don't cook anymore
they're out of the kitchen now you can't
just look at a woman and expect her to
not use a stove
she can't even turn the stove on this is
feminism at its finest
i've learned a lot on this episode
but hold on i want to say one last thing
because i will
uh uh our what
is that i am not fully a hundred percent
well yes and we know that and that's
okay
by the way that's okay which is why i
didn't want to do a podcast for so long
i was like i can't let people see my
real personality it's okay
everyone's like do a podcast when you do
a podcast throw me the fucking wolves
i didn't realize that youtube was the
piranha tank you did convince yourself
to do a podcast no i didn't everyone i
went on everyone else's podcast i was
perfectly fine being a guest for the
rest of my fucking life
driving to venice to do two fighters
diversions two fighters one you turned
around and somebody went i should do a
podcast no i did not
maybe i should not she's like they keep
pounding me too
not true and everyone said dude pockets
do a podcast and i was like all right
fine and then i was like she's crazy
it's like
yeah no shit that's why i only i i spent
eight months crafting something that
you'd see at the end of the year it was
all together and pulled together and i
didn't stutter and i looked my hair was
brushed now this whole thing of like i
have to be on camera every week with no
makeup artist
so what is your last bit of my last part
is i am not
fully a hundred percent solvent the way
you are with just i'm only gonna podcast
forever and i don't have to all those
skills that i fucking
like you you were a big swimmer imagine
never being able to swim again i mean
like i have all these skills and they
for nothing
right i cry for you and my heart bleeds
but those skills have made you good
money you have you have a great quality
of life
aesthetically on the outside and that
matters and you've been successful in
your industry and that that industry is
yes it's kaput but i do it's kaput
i mean it's over people in in major
movies have fifty thousand do you know
what it's like to be a woman
doing a podcast on youtube it is really
hurtful sometimes
it's only because people are listening
how do i what can i do to get my youtube
comments just a little more positive
i would suggest fuck jake paul no
i would suggest that
really the honest answer less
comedy talk less talk about the business
i don't feel like i do that
well because people
it's not it doesn't no one cares no one
cares no when someone comes on
no one cares i i agree yes and cancel
culture that's all anyone people come on
say i'm like we can't talk about this
again no one gives a shit but you have
only people
in the business on so it inevitably
steers to the business
interesting no one really i just want to
talk about ancestral trauma
and um no one wants that either no one
wants it either
here's what people want from a female
podcaster
murder stories anal discuss
anal for 30 hours a week that's no
is that i mean honest i mean that does
well kidding we either got to do that or
be christian amanpour
but here's what it is i came up with a
comic doing dirty jokes she's dirty
she's
like that just became something someone
liked
i did it 10 years ago people were like
she's blue i think the show's
good and you're building and you just
gotta keep building now yeah let
the only criticism i ever have about any
podcast really other than that they're
not good
is that uh no one cares about the
business of comedy
no one cares about any of that they just
want you to be funny about things
that are right that they see you got to
fill the void that
they're that the late night shows left
behind because they're so shitty
and all that stuff that's right and
that's why i'm a little surprised
because you are such uh
a devotee of of of the old system
i would be making it more of a show
that has a script with puns and and
no uh a higher production in the sense
of like not only just your productive
value is good but like
i would think you'd be doing a mini
tonight show that's i mean that's
what i tried to there were times where
we were doing like the jokes and news
and all that kind of stuff and i was
just like i don't know what the fuck is
it's very hard to ascertain what's
working here's here's why i do
about real estate here's selling real
estate i'd be a good realtor you'd be
great i'd be a great i can
i can because i'm such a good liar and i
never get to do it anymore
um but i would love to to do something
like that
yeah like to just trick people all the
time well i think it's a great show
i'm i'm happy always for the opportunity
to be on people
i mean i don't i these are epic episodes
people love them yeah
i mean you know what else it's also my
thing is also filling the void
that the roasts left because i think
adults really do enjoy
roasts and they know everyone's joking
and they know everyone's okay
and there's this new thing that
everyone's so fragile and no one can
take a joke
like i think that there's also a huge
void in that especially
a man like coming at a woman hard and
everyone's like women are made of glass
you're not allowed to say anything to us
ever because
it's like we're as strong as you but
we're also really super fragile like
which is it
so it's also um that i think as well
yes it is the fact that i have gone numb
i don't allow you to verbally abuse me
you're not
i don't verbally abuse you um what's
interesting
about these these is this generational
thing
we're similar ages we are right how old
are you 38
i'm 36. these are similar ages
and yet we are
coming from we have very different
experiences in the thing that we do
yeah you had one experience yeah i'm
having another experience yeah
and that is you know there's a collision
there
there's a tension there yeah you know
what i mean
i do think there's a day that you will
do
an a broadway show where you're doing a
monologue or a something
and you because there is a i'm not
against that okay yeah there is a
different less scott rudin producing of
course
um there is a level of like i did a tv
show recently just as like a whatever
and there is something about like
everyone's here to make this magical
thing it's silly it's like playing dress
up when you're a kid but here's why
that's so great and then everyone's
raping each other behind the scenes
you don't have one ben you don't have
any there's nothing
real it's all bullshit if you had one
ban
if you had one how much ben how much
this is what's your price to leave tim
i'm just curious i'm not gonna do it i'm
not gonna do it
but how much what would be if someone
came at you and was like rogan or
someone was like
i want you i need you full time what's
your number
to leave tim dillon uh i mean
i i want it and the reason is is like if
tim's done with the podcasting and
everything i'm just walking away from
everything
okay i like doing this with tim and no
one else
and his ben left but let's see what
happens when that offer comes in
if ben left my show i don't know that
i'd be able to do the show wow
i would have to do something else and
that's what i'd probably call you and
ask for 10 of your bullshit ideas
for you you trying to make him laugh is
my favorite
that's a real friendship yeah when you
go everyone's here and everyone's on
crack and raping each other
it's like nothing's real so you're like
oh you have something real but you don't
have 40 of it
it's like what interesting that's what
it is
less is actually more yeah you don't
need all the bullshit if you have
something
where you're comedically in sync with
somebody and you want to make something
cool and my biggest thing about this is
i
i it's hard am i getting paid for this
[Laughter]
you might get some frozen pizza or
macaroni
it will not be cooked it will be frozen
my thing is that
if if i am doing something as a comedian
going back on the road i know exactly
where i fucking stand i tell a joke i
know if you like it if you don't i know
the difference between a real approach
break and a forced one because
everyone's like proud of me and happy to
like i know
that's what i know i know how to uh put
something on the air and see the fucking
number
like this is a weird thing where it's
like it's it's
it's a skill that i don't quite have yet
which is to keep going
boldly in one direction with a bunch of
youtube comments
yelling at you and you're like i don't
know if i'm supposed to keep
going or if this is the right direction
or do i list
you i know not to take notes from
executive i know if an audience doesn't
laugh at a joke they're right
i don't know in the comment space who's
right
i know the numbers that's yeah you know
but then you see comments and you're
like if this was an audience of people
in front of me
and they were all like we don't think
that's funny i would stop doing it why
do you read who cares
i'm just saying it like it's it is a
part of the
thing when on youtube you've got thumbs
ups and thumbs downs i think if you
haven't grown up with it like i didn't
really grow up
yeah neither but that's why you
internalize it so much because a lot of
people that have grown up with it no
it's not real
and having the comments that are like
fuck you you suck are people if you
message him back like hey man i'm
actually a fan
i'm just trying to get it no one it
doesn't really matter what matters is
like
are people affected positively by the
shit you're doing interesting
and if there's 20 people that obviously
you want more
but if there's people that are affected
positively by what you're doing who
gives a fuck because it's like when you
do such hot fucking takes on shit like
last week i did this whole thing about
how we need billionaires and we need
people like elon musk because there have
to be incentives to do the shit you know
like it was just like
we're mad at billionaires until they
make penicillin or what you know what i
mean like our love
yeah people got mad at you with all the
the the uh
uh fucking the communist symbol why am i
blanking out on the swastika no
the uh oh the flag did they send me that
i don't know no but i'm just thinking so
what a bunch of people they
tweeted at you that you know a hammer
sickle is what i used to get my
face looking like i understood but yeah
so then they got maddie
about the billionaires well yeah it was
just kind of like a hot take and you're
kind of like are people going
i don't necessarily agree with that but
that's an interesting thought i mean
three times a week people tell me that
i'm the worst thing that's ever lived i
have people writing articles about me
that
i miss i'm not who cares yeah that means
they're listening but yeah it's one of
those things where like it's my job
comedy is a democracy i'm supposed to
listen to people but then you're kind of
i just get like lost in it and it's just
like
yeah but it's the same shit i mean most
of my comments
i would imagine i feel like they're just
ben
i would want that if somebody over had
been a crazy amount of money to leave me
i would want him to take the money and
then use it so that medium could do
other shit
oh cool yeah like there's always a way
for things to i i think that part of
what you can do your borah you can
part of what you're what you're doing
with the comments
is you're finding
reasons to feed the insecurity that
we all have you're looking for the
reasons right
if you look for it you'll find it yeah
yeah if i looked for homophobia i would
find it interesting
if you look for misery you find it
mm-hmm
you're a specialty yeah but like so
don't look for it
don't pick it up like aa has a great
saying don't pick it up yeah of course
it's there just don't pick it up yeah
so who gives a shit just do what you're
gonna do the
the the the
trade-off you make when you do anything
is that people have the right to hate
you they have the right to not like it
they have the right to disagree with you
they have the right to call you names
that's the trade-off and and what you
have the right to do
and the opportunity to do is you have a
platform
that you can then do what you want to do
which is so fucking rare and
that comes with the people that are
going well
fuck you i don't like it and that also
comes with people that go it's the best
thing ever
and it gets me through my week and you
gotta choose
who you're listening to tim dillon on
patreon tim
uh this will not get you through your
week it will make your week worse
to go to tim dillon.com my podcast
actually helps you get through hard
times tim dillon's creates the hard
times
he is toxic he is the opposite of a
mental wellness
program whitneycummings.com
to play her podcast you won't get far
you'll jump out the window
[Music]
okay fake bitch.net why not a dot com
because it's cool it's retro oh my god
don't ride elephants
[Music]
[Applause]
wow